In the 1980s, I heard about colostrum being used to combat cancer, is that still being used?
No, there are some cancers that don't do well with colostrum. I actually wrote an article about this
if you search the blog for colostrum and cancer. I think that's what the title of the article is called.
But it just talks about the pros and cons of colostrum. Usually I say most cancer patients don't
have a problem using colostrum. They want to help with their hair or their nails or something like
that, but it's not considered at all a cancer treatment any longer. There's pros and cons to
colostrum. It can accelerate growth in some cancers and there's some data that it can help with
people with cancer. So there's a lot of mixed data about colostrum out there. And I don't think it's
you know, there's a lot of data that's out there that's very biased, but I don't think it's unbiased.
I don't think it's biased. I think there's cause to be concerned about using excess colostrum
with cancer patients, especially if it's an epithelial cell cancer, like a colon cancer or something
like that. If a person had a lymphoma or something, I don't think there's any harm in using colostrum.
But you could check out that article on our blog.